the Sochi Olympics are starting on
Friday and I mean already this is
looking like a disaster between
obviously all the anti-gay stuff that
everybody's hearing about and the threat
of terrorism which every day they keep
leaking new information that something
may go down and just last night I saw a
report on NBC that the second people are
getting off the plane in Sochi when you
turn your phone on the hackers
immediately have access to your entire
phone now comes they are killing all the
stray dogs in Sochi as well a pest
control company which has been killing
dogs in Sochi for years because they
have to have some sort of animal control
as told the AP that they have a contract
to exterminate more animals during the
Olympics because they don't want people
getting bitten and I guess seeing stray
animals on TV and things like that we've
got a quote from the general of the pest
control firm he said a dog ran into the
fish Stadium we took it away god forbid
something like this happens at the
actual opening ceremony this would be a
disgrace for the whole country and now
we have a quote also from a lawmaker in
Sochi taking the dogs off the street is
Russia's responsibility to the
international community and their
elimination is the quickest way to solve
the problem alright so look I'm a dog
guy so this I immediately saw this story
and I don't want to see all these
animals killed and of course all the gay
stuff is horrible and there's all kinds
of other human rights problems there so
should we just not be surprised by this
in all kinds and God knows what China
was doing with dogs you four years ago
or you know whatever was so yeah exactly
so how much of a right do we even have
to complain when countries have to
supposedly do what they have to do to
clean up the place they're also they're
justifying the fact that this is a
threat to you know the amount of
tourists that are about to come into the
industry and the problems that these
ravy and non ravy dogs could have you
know with kids etc and in in the games
the different events you know I I don't
I don't know if you know and they're
talking about saying they're gonna build
dog kennels but but they haven't this is
Russia man yeah they're killing
the dogs they haven't even denied it in
this company that was subcontract gonna
have to do it has admitted openly that
there euthanizing the dogs we don't know
if they're shooting down yeah we don't
know what they're doing with these dogs
look I don't know if you've noticed but
you've seen all the the reporters are
starting to get there and revived and so
she ate if you've seen the reports them
coming in people are saying it's
arrested the hotels don't have running
water when they do it's brown doorknobs
are falling down some of the ceilings
are caving in and people have reported
stray dogs running in and out of hotel
rooms so obviously what we're seeing is
so she does not have their act together
they're a country that I think really
wanted to showcase and this you know in
front of the national international
community how Russia is glorious it was
like make benefit for glorious nation
show Sochi and Russia and I don't think
they were prepared so I think this is
just another one of their hysterical
scrambles to make Russia look bad or was
like round up all the dogs and it is a
legitimate concern you don't people
getting bit but obviously if your
country is such such to being close with
third world and country in certain
certain areas where it's run by that
maybe in the South Korea and was in
Austria are probably like are you
kidding me with them not getting the
Olympics and was giving it to a country
that was so ill prepared right so all
right so I don't to make this all about
the dogs but should we have two separate
Olympics this is what I'm starting to
think we need to have an Olympics for
the civilized nations that have basic
human rights look everyone does bad
things but basic human rights you treat
your women equally you treat your gay
people equally it's gonna be a small
group of Olympics and that one areas
but really should we have is it have we
gotten to a point in the world where
everything is so interconnected that
when they had the Olympics 100 years ago
you didn't know about everything
necessarily is going on in every country
now we have everything Instagram then
find and it's like you can see you can
literally see all the human rights
abuses so do we have to have some list
like you if you want to play with the
adults you have to have basic human
rights and and I understand that this
would exclude probably 60% of the
country and also there would be a lot of
discrepancies about what constituted
human rights is that their equal pay for
men and women is it that you don't jail
people without any recourse and all of
our legal systems and penal systems are
so different and attitudes and I think
what this is all about is trying to say
there is some sort of acceptance and I
think this is good because it's making
people aware of the way people live in
different countries and Russians have
different attitudes and Americans and
forget that Americans have different
attitudes than most of the world so
maybe it's us not that maybe we have a
higher standard of living we should be
really grateful instead of going out go
your streets are overrun with dogs and
you're killing then maybe be like wow
you live in a country where you actually
live in fear that pack some dogs might
overtake your home right come on we live
in a country that's sending drones
halfway across the world that been
blowing up weddings yeah I think what
people then protest us by saying that
you don't even have you're not even
sending your own people in a war anymore
you're descending drones in and I think
there's a lot of problems that the US
has that are completely different than
any problems the rest of the world can
relate to and vice versa so be really
difficult to come up with a
bullet-pointed list of what we thought a
bowl because we're very different
culturally even if we have very close
proximity because of Technology